what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i've gotten
so many requests for more one punch man
videos
and for one punch man chapter reviews so
here i am reviewing the latest chapter
of the one punch man manga if you want
to keep seeing one punch man manga
reviews on this channel
the best thing you could do is smash
that like button until it's blue and
share this video with any cultured one
punch man fans you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and make sure to select
all or you will miss future one punch
man videos
you can check out my existing one punch
man playlist where you'll find videos
about the s-class heroes
a-class heroes and on all known dragon
and god level threats
i'll link that playlist in the
description feel free to leave
suggestions for one punch
man videos you are dying to see in the
comments now without further ado let's
jump into this manga chapter spoilers
and all so as we know tatsumaki the
number two ranked s-class hero
was fighting psychos who had fused with
orochi
so right there we're already looking at
the combined powers of two dragon level
threats
last chapter we saw that psychos could
do planetary level damage
when we got a view from space of part of
the earth
actually getting sliced off tatsumaki
was surprised about where she was
getting so much power
and we are told that her energy level is
unmeasurable
psychos then tells us that she got
chosen by a great force who granted her
power greater than tatsumaki's
according to her it was a being like god
now this being has to be a god level
threat it called itself the master of
psychos and gave her what was called
unmeasurable energy that could actually
cause devastation on a planetary scale
we'll get more into whether this
empowered psychos should be considered a
god level threat now
but i don't really see this being was
even called god
not being god level but anyways psychos
went on to explain that she would use
her power to absorb all living creatures
with her roots
hoping to become the ultimate life form
the planet itself
in the process all humans would be
sucked into her and become one with her
along with the whole planet
now i know that she hasn't officially
been called god level but dragon level
is defined as a threat
endangering multiple cities while a god
level threat is defined as a threat
endangering the survival of all humanity
i think it's clearly being suggested
here that psychos
now has the power to endanger the
survival of humanity considering she
could potentially absorb
everyone and even if you ignore the
definitions the entity who gave her this
immense power must be a threat to all of
humanity
if it can pretty much create multiple
powerful beings like psychos
and that's not even getting into its own
full power
so even if it's not confirmed i think
it's clear that we have encountered what
could be considered a god level threat
already
in this chapter tatsumaki has to deal
with the insanely strong psychos who
starts launching deadly energy beams
everywhere
while trying to protect people and make
sure the beams don't hit the ground
tatsumaki spots king running with the
boy hostage
as usual tatsuwaki hilariously assumes
that king is not fighting the monster
because he's decided that tatsumaki's
powers would be more effective
she has no idea that this whole time
he's been more scared and freaked out
than the boy haas that she's trying to
save
as a tsunami caused by psycho threatens
to destroy a city
tatsumaki comes to the rescue a
beautifully illustrated
high-level psychic battle takes place
and it's cool to see tatsumaki being
pushed hard she's the strongest s-class
hero we've seen
while number one hero blast remains a
mystery so seeing her not just wreck
someone in a second is a pretty big deal
tatsumaki sends large boulders after
large
boulders flying at psychos but they're
easily dealt with tatsumaki is bleeding
at this point covered in dirt
while psychos seems completely fine
herself at this point without so much as
a scratch on her
as observing heroes look on at this
battle they can't help but remark
that it looks like the end of the world
and i really can't wait to see this one
animated
psychos appears to sense tatsumaki's
power which seems to give her x-ray
vision that lets her see through rocks
but this was actually a clever trick by
tatsumaki she focused enough power in
one place so that psychos thought she
was there but actually she snuck into
psychosis body
without her realizing it after calling
her bubble boobs
our tatsumaki uses a giant psychic
tornado to rip her apart from the inside
tatsumaki got through her powerful
barrier by going through the tower
directly below her
she disguised herself as the energy
cycles was absorbing
through her flesh roots and thus entered
her body ready to deal devastating
damage
it's interesting how tatsumaki used
psychos ability to sense energy
against her this long battle finally
looks like it's over and tatsumaki
starts extracting the heroes with all
her effort
rather than by using small amounts of
psychic power undetectable to psychos
she has it all mapped out she'll get
them out including the hilariously naked
puripuri prisoner
and then she'll crush the whole hideout
but then bam tatsumaki's hand gets
stabbed
and we see that whatever psychos has
become
is not done yet tatsumaki gets trapped
and then electrocuted
if she looked beat up before she looks
absolutely fried right now
she's hurt so bad that her psychic power
that was gently carrying people ceases
to work
that means that tatsumaki is seriously
damaged and i couldn't help but laugh
when the stoic
and calm atomic samurai's meditative
stillness was interrupted by the very
naked pudipuri prisoner
falling on his face man it just doesn't
get funnier than that that's the anime
version of bruno landing on eminem's
face
but much funnier psychos calls out
tatsumaki for lowering her guard
she proclaims she'll kill her and her
little sister she's got her trapped by
her punctured hands
and prepares to fire a point-blank
attack things do not
look good but a shot is fired from below
and it deflects psychosis's own shot
to her shock it is our boy demon cyborg
aka
jenos who came to the rescue of
tatsumaki who really did seem close to
her end right there
demon cyborg looks cool af and i love
how his path takes the form of a dragon
he launches another attack but is
overpowered yet another s-class hero
getting bested in a way by this new
psychos tatsumaki being her usual tunde
itself
doesn't thank genos for saving her but
gets mad saying king left psychos to her
however genos won't hear it he says
he'll take care of the beams while
tatsumaki
potentially finishes saving all the
endangered heroes including her sister
even jenos thinks that saitama is their
only hope here
jenos immediately decided to go with his
last resort
and use his full power which will only
last 10 seconds
and he wonders if it'll be enough in the
midst of this intense moment we get
cliffhangered
and jump to others tatsumaki's sister
who can sense the power of psychos is
visibly freaking out
saying there are unimaginable forces up
there now this isn't weird for one punch
man an enemy is hyped up and then
saitama is disappointed by how easily he
finishes them off
despite the hype but still i can't help
but enjoy all this talk about
unmeasurable and unimaginable power
meanwhile we jump to saitama and these
panels are completely juxtaposed to the
epic life and death battle we were just
experiencing saitama complains about
being hungry
as he works towards slowly unbearing
flashy flash who doesn't look so flashy
stuck between rocks
i gotta admit i'm starting to grow fond
of this monster who was originally
trying to kill saitama and flashy flash
the conversations and bonding they're
going through is hilarious the monster
tightens a belt around his stomach
like really tight and says that that
helps to lessen the feeling of hunger
at first saitama just thinks he looks
weirder than ever and says he doesn't
understand monsters but he quickly
changes his mind when his stomach keeps
growling from hunger
he proceeds to tighten his belt and he
admits that maybe
it did help a little while the monster
tells him that he told him so this is
like a mundane silly convo that you'd
have
with your friend but it's happening
between saitama and the monster and that
makes the mundane comedic that's pretty
much what one punch man is about
emphasizing the mundane
in a fantastical superhero world where
you don't expect to find it
saitama proceeds to say that this
monster must have the ultimate
intellect which draws a parallel to
psychos who claim to have the ultimate
intellect
as she was kicking s-class hero butt and
trying to straight-up end humanity for
her it's the biggest deal for saitama
it's anyone who can help him feel a
little bit less hungry
the monster wants to include flashy
flash so that all three of them look
ridiculous with super tight belts but
flashy flash is not amused
and wants no part of it he's a dude who
unlike saitama takes himself way too
seriously and is very concerned with his
hero image which you'll see with many
heroes in this world
while flashy flash thanks god that no
one is around to see him in such an
embarrassing situation
cytomind the monster continue to work
and talk about what saitama is going to
eat later
they appear to settle on curry and so
this chapter that began so action-packed
and intense ends with the slow tedious
work of lifting rocks
and a conversation about curry and
although i want to know what happened
with the fight i welcome such
contrasting moments
it's true that even when we're living
our dreams like saitama is by being a
hero for fun we still spend a lot of our
time
thinking about practical everyday stuff
like what we're gonna eat later
and having to do tedious stuff here and
there the fact that one punch man can
combine the shonen genre we love and
find so entertaining with the less
glamorous realities of everyday life
makes it entertaining relatable bizarre
and absolutely hilarious all at the same
time
can't wait for more humor and more
action on the next one
let me know what you think is gonna
happen next are tatsumaki who appeared
to be in awful shape at some points
and genos gonna be able to pull off the
w without saitama
or is saitama gonna have to show up and
if he does how easy is it gonna be for
him to win
that is the question and give me any
theories you have about this god figure
he's as mysterious as blast at this
point
so many interesting loose ends that i
can't wait to see tied up
if you did enjoy this one punch man
review and want to keep them coming the
best thing you can do is smash that like
button until it is blue if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all
or you will miss future one punch man
videos you can check out my existing one
punch man playlist as you wait for the
next review
where you'll find videos about the
s-class heroes a-class heroes
and on all known dragon and god level
threats i'll link that playlist in the
description
feel free to leave suggestions for one
punch man videos you are dying to see
in the comments a very special thank you
goes to our patrons over on patreon who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one to your
patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alola
nothing the world
steelers acquire respect pate hepa
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf
emperor otaku thomas jones ken mano
and admirath and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh who's
the current most donated overall
champion of the world nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings elders anatoly
kazatsky angel cruz cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica kayla fond hinokami and water
bonnie
aura deadly saint and stern hawkins
thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as well as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these epic people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com anime upload link in the
description if you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button
next to the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you